[Music]
please don't get involved
what is up thickies monday morning
monday monday
how is everybody man everybody good
great grand
uh wonderful off the plane from
baltimore maryland
baltimore gotta be honest baltimore is
uh one of the very few cities i've ever
done stand up in and baltimore um
is one of my favorite cities they get a
bad rap but baltimore's fantastic now
when i say they get a bad rap i didn't
go to like the wire areas i was
uh staying in lower harbor which
apparently is
a good area a nice area one of my
favorite hotels is out there the pantry
so uh this is a good time man baltimore
is like uh
baltimore's like atlanta and
philadelphia had a baby and you mix
those together and that's what you get
um
before i went out there because i've
never been out there i hit up all my
fellow comedian buddies i said baltimore
what's it like who's done the club and i
get like uh
mixed messages a lot of people went oh
it's great let people oh it's terrible
but around the board everyone goes it's
it's the roughest crowd on the east
coast rougher than boston new york
philly be ready man it's a rough crowd
like all right
thursday show
great
friday's show
great zero issues saturday early great
i'm like man what are you guys talking
about
saturday late show
david uh they're a little rowdy oh
saturday late they've been drinking
whatever
and uh
show started at i think nine you know
probably started about 9 30 what time we
got sat and you know the line blah blah
blah so then uh there's a couple in the
back the way the magubes uh venue is
structured out there it's almost like a
mini theater it's not like your
conventional like improv where it's like
one level it's like
one main level and then like then it
like tears up like a theater
so there's a couple sitting at the top
like getting on the balcony there and
they're they're just chatting during the
you know the opener then the mc the
feature and then i two features right so
then uh dave lucas gets up and he's
talking about about baltimore how bad
crime is
and the lady who was talking the whole
time yells out clearly drinking and
they're not young either that's the
thing they're not young
she yells out uh oh please baltimore's
better than la
and
you know she was talking the entire set
so finally david had to address it and
david lucas for those of you that don't
know he's my feature on the road he's
part of the thick boy team that's him
right there
and uh he um
you know decide to do his thing if you
don't know david david is a professional
roaster he's on kill tony he got his
fame from kill tony um he's actually on
a roast battle show
there couldn't be a worst guy to heckle
and whenever somebody heckles david all
the comics come out of the green room
because we're like oh here we go it's
like a ticking time bomb
he lights this couple up for
probably 15 minutes at least i mean
absolutely annihilates this lady an hour
later
i came here the whole thing now we're
gonna post the clip of it today it's
around two three minutes
but once we include david's
um
you know because it's probably around i
don't know i don't know it's gonna be a
longer clip which will upload later but
on socials we can't do the whole thing
so you'll see a little snippet of it but
he absolutely annihilates this wife and
the husband and he's talking to the
husband how you know you get her in line
why she's speaking why she destroys them
and even i was like geez this is a lot
man
so security comes to kick him out and
dave goes no no no leave him leave him
and so he keeps going lighten them up
so
if you know anything about usually even
though he roasts them in
in history of comedy usually they don't
get better they don't just go okay i got
lit up and i'm drunk i'm gonna pipe down
now usually they get worse the more they
drink so david tells security to leave
them so then i go on stage
and then they keep talking but it was i
was all right it was you know they're
far enough back or i could power through
it
but the people around them i kept
hearing rum was like shut up shut up
pipe down i was like oh that's not good
keep doing my thing then finally i hear
shut the [ __ ] up
and so what was happening is the drunk
couple again not young i would say
mid-40s by 50 but not a small dude lady
wasn't small either
the dude
below him there was a group a table
and they were younger and the guy who
him and his wife got roasted was that
must had a king-sized kitkat bar because
he kept throwing pieces of kitkat at the
table
he kept throwing p and finally the dude
had it and i just hear this scuffle and
then i look up and i see homeboy
who i reference him he looks like a
jersey shore character like one of the
cast we look like paulie d he [ __ ]
climbs over the railing and jumps in the
air and superman punch him like he's a
thick ass anthony pettis so the whole
crowd gets up and looks and then from
there the older dude shoots the worst
double egg you've ever seen the guy
jersey shore sprawls and continues to
beat the [ __ ] out of him and the wife
went running
and so they finally you know the
security finally gets them kicks him out
but during the height of this during
like it's going on for i don't know two
three minutes
as he's beating him up i hear some
gentleman scream as loud as he can
twist his dick off
which was fantastic for me because where
do you go after that but i was able to
ride and rift on the twist's dick off
gentlemen for quite some time and my
team recorded a good amount of it they
miss
the majority of the fight because you
know
we those green room diary bits they
record the first 10 minutes and then
once i get the baltimore stuff out of
the way they shut down they're not
recording my whole set so they shut down
in the back but once the fight you know
by the time they set their cameras up
they got a lot of it and they got thanks
to mark and all the angelo and the rest
of the guy shooting they got a lot of it
they got we got like one-on-one
interviews with the twister's dick off
kid we got one-on-one interviews with
the guy who whooped his ass so
twist his dick off happens you know i
was able to riff on that they kicked him
out but i didn't think he was fair
because that guy was doing he was a he
was getting you know constantly
harassed with kit kats which i would
just ate them and kept watching the show
but i'm fat
so
they kicked this poor guy out who's
doing the lord's work because again the
security there this isn't a knock down
with goobies one of the best clubs i've
ever been to hands down great club
um
but you know the security there is the
owner's son who's 19 years old or 20
and then you know some of the staff but
they're not security so
they somehow get them out
and then i'm going through myself i'm
like where is the guy like they kicked
him out like oh no no we got to find him
that guy did me a solid that guy has
been a disturbance the entire [ __ ]
show that guy okay he's a hero and i
looked at the staff and my team like get
go someone go find him he's still
outside
and homeboy was still outside and they
got him back in and we got him on stage
and just realized like what happened
dude you know and then also his shirt
came off i thought he ripped her shirt
off but apparently the shirt got grunt
you know [ __ ] during the fight got
ripped off but uh
yeah it was a fun one it was a fun
something you know those things can go
south listen i've seen fights in crowds
before you ain't never seen a dude that
looks like pauly d from jersey shore
throw a flying freaking
superman punch off the top ropes man and
then when he comes back in you'll see
when we post the video today when he
comes back in he's with us he's with his
girl and his best friend he his best
friend six eight three hundred i'm like
hold up who's this he's like that's my
best friend i go where were you
what were you doing
and i was like you look like shaquille
o'neal and freaking white face dude how
are you not how did you not help your
friend out and then
we can't air that interview mark
interviewed him he's like yo man i you
know i'm on
probation man i can't be involved with
this [ __ ] man so please don't hear this
stuff he's like and i didn't want to get
you know i don't want any issues man
because another strike and i'm screwed i
was like oh my god dude
oh my god
so um
you know it i guess uh baltimore lives
up to their uh
to the hype but you know to be fair to
mugubes and baltimore in general i love
baltimore one of my favorite venues i've
ever performed that even in the freaking
summer in august which is most comics
it's the off season um but because i
never played it we thought it would be a
good play and we were right man to to
sell that well in the summer is tough to
do man tough to do so shout out to
baltimore got this dope ass uh orioles
jersey now here's the thing about when
you wear jerseys like this around town
and you're not um from that city or a
fan is i will uh walk around today to
get my starbucks someone goes dude and
they'll tell me how the orioles are
doing or you know
i just buy the jerseys dude i don't if
someone came through like dude i will
give you one million dollars to name one
player on the baltimore orioles
you can do it couldn't do it anybody
doing in here
orioles
cal ripken
that's all i go to that's my cal ripken
how about that from the 90s dumbass
that's all i got for you
i know some baseball but i know the
dodgers and chargers i mean sorry
chargers there you go
san diego charges baseball man the
padres she's got soto so on the yankees
and [ __ ] like that but outside that bad
it gets dicey with my baseball knowledge
but yeah that's the problem we're
wearing these jerseys and the yesterday
i'm at the car show with my kiddos
which they finally shut down finally the
[ __ ] business owners were able to
kick um
kick the the car show out they've been
trying to do it forever forever
and uh they finally are successful man
finally successful it's been going on
for years my my my oldest t tiger six he
he loves it he loves going the whole
thing
but boston at two is ups it's literally
the highlight of his week so i gotta
figure out we still went there they we
still do our thing but there's not the
cars they're miserable so we got to
figure it out man we got to freaking
figure it out but i know there's more uh
they're going to move it to somewhere
else
anyone involved that
malibu cars and coffee please let me
know where you move it because my
two-year-old is not happy he wants to
talk to hr and good luck with that he's
a feisty one they were pissed dude and i
was like oh there's always the parking
lot's always full so they're not going
to notice wrong
my sexual like doesn't look like there's
so many priuses i was like oh my god now
see like one decent card i'm like oh
look there's a
cadillac cts
oh check it out there's a
tesla and they're like get the hell out
of here damn like fair enough fair
enough so hopefully uh
wherever you move it spike i know you're
watching spike let me know where you
guys move it too man you got to keep me
posted my two-year-old is freaking the
hell out
they're both in crocs i'm ruined my
monday so that's whatever uh let's get
to the fights man let's get to the
freaking fight
you had actually a really good uh fight
night on uh saturday night it's the
ultimate fighter 30 heavyweight
tournament an ultimate fire 30 women's
flyweight tournament with the main event
being jamal hill and thiago santos
santa's fallen on hard times man and it
makes sense that jamal hill was the
favorite going into this
but jamal hill is a guy who what theo
thiago santos even though he's falling
on hard times you know he's still a
staple of the light heavyweight division
remember you know he went to i think
what split decision with jon jones and
he's following really hard times so he's
lost five out of his last six
um his last win coming over johnny
walker which in hindsight doesn't look
that impressive these days but previous
to that but you know
santos was the guy kevin he beat kevin
holland so first of all let me go over
some of his wins for you guys just so
you realize what you're dealing with
here although
i mean he was at middleweight and uh
struggled there but you know he got
knocked out by giger mousasi but he did
beat nate markhart which is a big deal
could be biased because that guy's my
team captain whatever um so when he uh
you know he beat gerald merchart no punk
you beat jack hermansen no punk at all
he'd be anthony smith definitely no
[ __ ] punk lots of david branch all
right and then uh he beat kevin holland
no punk eric anders no freaking punk uh
jimmy manawat dude ridiculous uh yawn
former champ tko'd him third round tko
him and then they give him a title shot
against jon jones he loses by split
decision some people thought santos won
that fight after that fight it gets very
dicey for him because he fights clover
taxera loses
fights racket loses they give him uh uh
so that's three losses in a row they
give him johnny walker he beats johnny
by uh unanimous decision not the best
fight of you know the night by any means
looking back on that johnny walker's
just not that level
and then uh he lost a mega med
nothing to hang your head on and you
know decision but again tough road then
you get jamal hill
so even though santos who's lost to the
tip of the spirits beat some of the very
best you know he's five out of six
losses here with the only win coming
over a young guy who's struggling in
johnny walker
but jamal hill is a guy that i know the
hardcores and the the die hards have
been keeping their eye on
um but he doesn't have that big kind of
signature win now he does beat he did
beat osp
uh he lost to paul craig
paul craig's a guy where you'll see you
realize why he should be running tire
but you'll see he he'll just pull some
of these things out of his ass the paul
craig's wins you're like what paul craig
beat him it's nuts uh real badass so
lost so he beat osp lost to paul craig
then beat jimmy croot no punk knocked
him out performance of the night then
they give him johnny walker who santos
uh beat as well he knocks him out in a
horrible knockout before so he gets two
performance of the nights back to back
then they give him thiago santos fight
of the night i guess you should give
five tonight there's some exchanges that
that were fun and jamal hill did uh
entertain it and get hit with some big
punches and just kept coming jamal hill
to me is one of those guys that you're
going to want to watch because like you
see there's nothing there's nothing
better in pro sports
when a young prospect is coming up
through the rankings now jamal hill is
going to be ranked probably seven or six
now so
the come up is
you're kind of late on the train but you
can still jump on because he still has a
few more fights before he becomes uh the
champion if he does but it's a fun ride
man jamal hill's a fun guy to watch i
was impressed with his takedown offense
even though thiago santos took him
around five times i think thiago shot 15
times
at least you know it is a five round
fight
and thiago santos
you know who's a veteran who's not known
for his grappling or his uh wrestling
capabilities to shoot that many times
and biz being alluded to this you're
going to be exhausted i'm going to [ __ ]
who you are you could be gsp you could
be khabib you shoot that many times man
you're get you're you're you're in sixth
gear the entire fight you're running it
hard man so
once his gas tank kind of came to an end
that's when jamal hill really started
going to work landed some big uppercuts
thiago santos was so tired at one point
he turns his back that's where he gets
clipped then jamal his thing beat him in
the fourth round but
such a marquee win for jamal hill next
for him i know he called out i think he
said he only wants champs or former
champs
him for jan blackovich would be a
phenomenal fight thiago santos did beat
him but for jamal hill at light
heavyweight they could use it man they
really could he he's a guy he's
definitely got to watch so you know they
haven't updated the uh the rankings yet
but he was at 10. so you gotta assume i
would assume he jumps to six or five
because
anthony smith do they
no they left him at five
uh mogamed's three now rockets four then
yet young glover than your champierry so
i would assume he jumps to six
dominic reyes vulcan um yeah so but for
hill i would assume next for him is a
big boy fight yawn makes sense
john vs hill is a phenomenal fight i
would love that fight for him so he's
one to watch them and he's a fun dude to
watch from chicago fights out of detroit
quick hands
you know um
something you would be wary about is you
know
again thiago santos isn't exactly a
world champion wrestling that's not his
pedigree he did take him down five times
but he did shoot a sh [ __ ] truckload
um and he really didn't do much
when it was down there jamal hill got
back to his feet but if he fought like a
mugger med um you know yon can wrestle
um
that'd be the only caveat there you'd be
like you know if it does get down you
know those guys are gonna be better
grapplers so who knows but his hands are
so goddamn good his boxing is crispy boy
man it was good
so shout out jamal hill uh
you could give a few mvps and also this
card these cards always fly under the
radar we're like yeah the car is not
that fun but dude you're talking every
single fight ended in a freaking
submission or tko or ko all finishes
this is a fun fight card to watch um
you know there's a few mvps on this but
i would say you gotta give mvp to uh
neil our boy texas roadhouse neal
you know he looked absolutely phenomenal
took some time off vicente lucas never
been finished you know he's been a
favorite in every single one of his
fights vicente lucay is a [ __ ]
monster even when you hit him he keeps
coming forward
but neil from the that first round left
some big shots kind of [ __ ] him up
wobbled him second round neil's been
known to take second rounds off neil did
take the second round off vicente lucas
assume won that second round but that
first round he go 10-8 um you know so
going into the third
he again he landed some more big shots
and one two crisp one-two landed and
then dropped vicente luke who's never
been finished so that is a huge feather
in the cap for neal so i'll probably
give him mvp for finishing with sunday
luke 8 again this common theme here with
jamal hill and neil you know they both
it was kind of fork in the road are
these guys going to be contenders are
you guys and they uh showed up man and
got the job done uh kamar usman's older
brother who's jack city with tat
mohammed usman uh a check hook knocked
out zach
and uh you know
the ref i don't blame the ref you can't
get there in time and uh usement lands
some big shots on the ground big big
shots both denver boys
both denver boys both training on the
same temperatures yeah very interesting
um july miller got it done against
brogan great name brogan
um
in the third round so that's the feather
in her cap other than that man um you
know sam alvey just to you know you
can't the guy has so many fights you
gotta mention sam albee sam alvi the
smiling assassin that's what i like to
call him i think he comes
smiling sam alvey or some [ __ ] like that
he's lost nine fights in a row
nine fights
it's the the longest
you know skid in the ufc he just he was
tied with bj penn bj uh you know
lost eight but bj's also a former world
champion one of the most famous guys to
ever do it so semi told you spin before
ufc vegas 59 that he would make 96k
total if he lost that's a solid payday
i'm sure he's been in the in that
ballpark for a minute it's easy for me
to say but i don't think he should
continue to risk yourself brutal that's
the other thing too now on those nine
fights that he's lost there's a few
split decisions there that i think even
the ufc will admit that he won those but
it doesn't really matter because the end
of the day you lost nine fights in a row
father of three i think is the girl's
pregnant again
um
you know for sam you know now he's has
he lost nine fights but he takes damage
too so something you gotta worry about
is it dad how long do you want to keep
doing this dude and i think he even
mentioned an article with espn
you know he's like this is probably my
last one especially oh my god he's like
um yeah this thing takes punishment you
know what's interesting about him is
when i was a coach on the ultimate
fighter during the roy nelson shane
carwin uh season 14.
sam was on that cast and sam was a guy
who
i had no clue he was gonna have this
career because he was a guy who
you know he didn't want to train one day
he didn't feel well and he kind of had
some quit in him so we didn't think much
of him and he goes on to you know have
some
you know
he had a good career you know like he as
many as he had some like 25 ufc fights
his problem too is he never said no to
the ufc which is good and bad that's
because he
never said no they gave him uh the the
leash of losing eight fights in a row
and still gave him another fight
he beat rashad evans he beat nate
markhart jesus christ kevin casey
um
he's a tough go a little nog jimmy crew
ryan spann
you know
brendan allen you know and not only
he has a few decisions in there but most
his losses are bad you know so
he even talked about um if the ufc cuts
him going to bellator or bkfc it's like
just [ __ ] stop
you know
but shout out to sam alvey smiling sam
it's a tough gig
tough gig
anthony penis lost again huh he did and
apparently he broke both of his hands
his strike doesn't look good but you
know just the grappling
yeah just the grappling that stevie
kid's just a better grappler
you know the pfl anthony pettis
experiment really hasn't come to
fruition that's tough for the pfl very
very tough when your marquee fighter's
not making into the finals you know
that's what they needed
what are you gonna do man you know
what are you gonna do
sucks for him yeah let's take a little
break from talking about these
fisticuffs because listen man for all
your summer travels whether you're going
abroad or staying domestic and want to
immerse yourself in the culture of where
you're going now's the perfect time to
start even at my age with babel babel is
the language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions it's easy
it's fun it's bite sites language
lessons there's still time to learn a
new language before you reach your
destination or that age you're like i'm
38 i can't do it yeah you can because
your boys learn spanish that's right
with babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you start having
real life conversations a new language
in little as three weeks
other
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 150 language experts all right
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with bow we can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish like your
boy here french italian or german plus
babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your accent there's so
many ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast games video stories even live
classes plus
most of all it comes with a 20-day back
money guarantee start your new language
learn journey today with my friends at
babel and guess what right now when you
purchase a three-month babel
subscription you get an additional three
months free that's six months for the
price of three just go to babel.com use
promo code shop s-e-h-a-b that's
babel.com promo code shob b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com promo code shop
listen inflation's pop and daddy what if
i told you there was an app an app where
you're eating at your favorite
restaurant you're at the gas station
you're buying groceries and you're
getting up to seven percent cash back
that's right my friends at upside it's
an incredible app for anyone who buys
gas groceries or you eat out do you do
all those things well guess what with
every purchase your boy here is earning
cash back thanks to upside to get
started download the free upside app use
the promo code shop s-e-h-a-u-b and get
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
all right for me with these gas prices
that are through the roof i use upside
on my gas man so when you're complaining
about oh it's up two dollars guess what
for your boy it's evening out because
i'm using upside i save money whenever i
fill up the tank on my rides thank god
for upside
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week that's
probably why they have a 4.8 star rating
on the app store
telling you man you want to save some
money we're in inflation you're buying
groceries you're eating out your
favorite restaurants maybe at work right
now you go to the same restaurant all
the time i'm willing to bed upsides on
there and not only you're eating out but
you can cash back it's lowering your
monthly bills lowering your monthly
payouts download the free upside app and
use the promo code shop s-e-h-a-b get
five dollars more cash back in your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
that's five buckaroos or more cash back
on your first purchase of ten dollars
more using promo code shop download the
upside app right now use the promo code
shop
you gotta fight this weekend you gotta
fight night you gotta it's great the
main event's great the rest card is
garbage but uh and again
no shade on anybody on the undercard but
uh yes
uh cynthia talvio who i always enjoy
watching nina nunes that's a great fight
in women's flyweight division
merchants on there against bruno silva
that's a good fight you know it's not
garbage what am i talking about devin
clark's fighting on there that's a good
one
angela hill uh it's not bad and then
your main event marlon dominic cruz this
is a home game for dominic cruz this is
in san diego dominic's hometown
tough fight for dom regardless you know
dom's last fight i think i'm third on
the prelims and he got the job done
against uh casey um you know it's a
little bit of slap in the face to him um
so he fight casey in vegas and then he
fights pedro munoz beats pedro
um
and that's fight of the night so you
know now he's fighting the main event in
his hometown
only grace to ever do it there's
argument he is the greatest to do it at
that weight class at bantamweight you
know he's a legend um
tough fight for him regardless where the
fight's at
you know i love dom one of the greatest
minds to ever do it one of the greatest
fighters ever do it phenomenal analyst
it's just so crazy to me and he has that
kobe mentality he's such a [ __ ]
savage um
you know so he he's fighting he wins
this one i would assume
the winner of this gets a big boy fight
whether it's cheeto or dom regardless
who wins this fight gets a big boy fight
because al jermaine and tj who knows
what happens there if there's injuries
or anything like that nestle you also
have peter yan sugarshot o'malley um you
know so
i think ufc is doing this they have
options you could give either the winner
of
suga or peter yon or the winner of
dominic or cheeto a shot at the title
and nobody being upset about it so
they're gonna have so many options in a
few months here because tj and al
jermaine fighting uh abu dhabi and then
you got these guys these boys fighting
so uc's gonna have a ton of options
makes sense
makes sense i'd love it for my boy
cheeto guy title shot i absolutely love
cheeto phenomenal story but also i love
dom too so if dom won you know it's a
great story as well
because you could also the winner of
this and if sugar were to win and they
don't want to give suga a title shot
right away you know sugar matches up
pretty well with mar uh with cheeto and
donut cruz and has a history of both of
them so either way you go the ufc wins
here
smart matchmaking what do you got jen
um real quick to recap that ufc fight
that just happened there's a girl
this girl cory mckenna she pulled i
thought she made history with by pulling
off the first von fluchok for a girl
well that's dope
they want to rename this the osp choke
because open st proof got so many
submissions like this
all right uh so the biggest news
ufc 281 it's going to be stylebender
which is alex baillia to headline the
madison square garden card fantastic
yeah
i don't know i just think
izzy passes with flying colors me and
count have five thousand dollar bet on
it five thousand
well that's november 12th
msg and they also say about between pory
and chandler's being discussed yeah
i talked to chandler last week about and
he's like dude i haven't heard anything
yeah i heard that so he's not even in
talks do you think or he just was like
he was like you'll know what i know dude
he's like you know the ufc and brett
akuma have to release it but as soon as
i hear anything else i'll call it yeah
but
dustin so far is a minus 155 favorite
makes sense
it's a great fight though mm-hmm
and here's the opening odds for
arizona ooh close
close yep minus 164. out of sonya
um great fight mm-hmm
this is your boy rapaport talking about
jake paul oh no rapport trying the
headlines again
hold
up pull
fake pull don't front stop the lying and
the ball crapping seized on the pca
chair it was supposed to go down in the
world's most famous arena madison square
garden didn't get cancelled because of
some weight thing
to the fifth time that you were gonna
dig you're gonna fight him
it got canceled because no one bought
tickets
that's not true okay because the ghosts
of madison square garden the same arena
where i'll leave fort frazier where jake
lamotta fought sugar ray robbie's were
hulk hogan
how dare you throwing hulk hogan how
how dare you rapport i want to see you
in there no one bought tickets to that
fake fight fake pull you're not a
fighter you want to be a real fighter
fight a real fighter okay
take a real drug test
okay
the rules the con the bull jive is over
fake paul
hmm
yeah no idea what's going on
i know you get views that's for sure
and uh here's chelsea and also
commenting on cheekbone so bottom ramen
why is everybody pulling over on the
side of the road like it's breaking news
all right
but it's funny he calls him top ramen
now he's calling bottom ramen
the agreed upon weight class is 200
pounds he comes in at 206.6
but there was a remedy suggested by the
new york state athletic commission the
remedy suggested was to move the fight
to 205 pounds he failed twice and then
put it out for the world to see speaking
it was gonna justify him this is an epic
fail so bottom ramen so he made the
weight of two he still weighed in for
whatever reason for 206 on august 6th
yeah but it was like still over the
women yeah so he still didn't make
weight still didn't make probably cast
it out
and then he also released
so ramen
i guess he released footage of uh jake
let me see it okay
now remember this is
old as [ __ ] content creator we're going
to see on august 6 man
i i for the life of me i don't know why
jake paul wants to do this
i hate those days
oh
[Music]
that check hooks nasty he's only using
his left hand
too yeah he's not using anything else
but his left hand
was that the deal they made with him
there's right
boom
[Music]
shoulder
yeah it looks like it would have been a
good fight though
yeah in this footage he you know he's
beating him but you gotta remember
jake paul is getting
better by the [ __ ] minute and the the
awesome part about jake paul is like
because he this is roman junior's claim
like he can edit it the way he wants and
just put a little bit out correct so
then jake says
he released the entire footage like a 19
minute video oh really yeah jake
released it which is just freaking out
in his footage
he's just like
everyone can watch the entire thing so
it's not edited and i'm sure i mean it's
19 minutes from two and a half years ago
y'all
[Music]
[Music]
huh anyways but the fact that jake
released the entire thing is kind of
dope yeah pretty dangerous yeah
and they went back and forth yeah wish
that fight would have happened
yeah
all right and then jake paul was trying
to fight ksi
he tried to case i
shot him down essentially saying all
this he beat the [ __ ] out of him you
fought a man fresh out of hip surgery
you fought a
a beat
you fought and beat a pastor's prime
woodley with three weeks notice you made
a gibb fight at a weight you should
struggle to reach this list goes on all
that ain't gonna work for me fam jake
paul jake would beat the [ __ ] out of it
i think so too
but also for jake
don't do that jake don't don't find a
youtuber that's not going to help
anything let me be a paid at mass square
garden don't do that
let me play this real quick
guys this is absolutely absurd what ksi
just did here he is now fighting
one of his friends talk about getting
paid to take a dive he's fighting a
rapper
that is his friend that they've made
songs together
who has never fought before
the dude has a t-shirt on in the fight
poster then you have a picture of this
guy shirtless what the [ __ ] is going on
this event should be for free even ksi's
fans right now are saying yo what is
going on ksi they want to sell their
tickets to the event
this is what i would expect from you
ksion you taking an easy fight an easy
way out your friend who's gonna just
take it yeah he's not a fighter
he's a youtuber
i mean
yeah but for jake like don't don't go
that route you're about to fight a legit
guy and rahm and junior and now you're
coming for ksi a straight up youtuber
that makes sense i mean it's about the
views and money still yeah you know
okay so jake also said this
he has a new company i think
i turned down 40 million
here's why i single-handedly revived
time to reinvent the sports landscape
with my new company better i got this
[ __ ] [ __ ] tatted on my leg that's how
much this company means to me that's
better we have two
the first being a sports media content
factor i'm launching my own weekly
sports show called bs with jake paul
stephen a smith pat mcafee skip bayless
shannon sharp there's a new sheriff in
town surprise [ __ ] the second
branch of better is sports betting and
online that's where the money is never
really a big sports bettor until i met
my co-founder joey levy who introduced
me to micro betting what is micro
betting you may ask our app allows you
to bet on every single play score drive
and player in real time i was offered 40
million dollars from one of these crypto
casino companies but turned it down this
year because what we're doing at better
is better better is gonna take over this
whole [ __ ] industry stay tuned
aggressive yeah so he's gonna have a
weekly show
yeah invest in yourself i take it
40 mils quite a lot don't try and fight
ksi though
okay so mike tyson's pissed off at hulu
because i guess they did a new series
covering mike tyson but they didn't pay
him anything the guy didn't look like
mike tyson i know you've seen it it
looks like the trail is pretty cool
though i'm not into it soon i sound like
[ __ ] it's hard to find someone that
looks like him and
but they've already shot a straight up
movie a motion picture with jamie foxx i
know that's like jamie foxx like put on
weight for it it's jamie
foxx that's some unknown actor
so hulu this is mike tyson tweeting i
said hulu tried to desperately pay my
brother dana white millions that offered
me a dollar to promote their slave
masters takeover
uh story about my life turned it down
because he honors friendship and
treating people with dignity i will
never forget what he did for me
um yeah i mean he has 400 million mike
right so it's easier money when you have
money but also pretty cool if dana white
all right dana's a complicated guy so
hulu stole my story which is insane how
can they steal his life rights and just
blast it out and not pay him they're
goliath and i'm david heads will roll
for this what's going on here
um hey hulu i'm not a
n-word
you can sell on the auction block
slavery is over f you hulu whose model
of stealing life rights of celebrities
is
greedy hashtag heads will roll i i don't
get how they can get his life rights and
put it out there i don't either then
nathan nate diaz has his back i'm with
you
i'm whitney bike and he goes [ __ ] hulu
listen um
um
love island's on hulu so
i can't end my subscription someone
should get fired from hulu producer
lying to my friend saying i support the
unauthorized series about my life
yeah that's ridiculous he's super pissed
off yeah it's insane yeah i would be too
especially the movie's coming out like
this i
the negative press on this i won't watch
it no chance
all right this is what um nick diaz's
coach is saying about nick when he
fought robbie lawler that he had two
ruptured discs in his neck and now he
has two titanium discs or something so
that's why he didn't fight as well
didn't train as well
so he he did just have he just didn't
have any strength he didn't have what
you're used to the nikki as you know he
didn't have it so we're finally able to
go and get an operation and put the
titanium disc in his neck so he's
feeling great from
that right now it's like we're getting
the old nick back which is really good
so now that that's happened waiting for
doctors you got another appointment i
think next month then should be cleared
to start his hard training again because
right now he can only run hit pads
and everything but he definitely wants
to fight in the ufc i've been in contact
with them
they just actually called me the other
day asked about nick and there's some
pretty cool fight options that are in
front of us oh i bet
um
it should be fun especially if this is
true and he's really healthy now
all right two more injuries so anthony
smith he did
you know he did i think dana white said
he didn't break his leg but then
eventually he apologized that he did but
it's a fracture a weird one in the
middle where you can't even put a plate
in it
they just have to go in and somehow like
reconnect it name this food truck for it
yeah
uh this is dana oh this is anthony it's
in such a weird spot they can't even
played it it's like a continuation of my
leg bone it's a medial
malleolus break and there's another bone
that's discolored that won't go back in
until they fix it it's not like a
typical combat sports break it's a weird
break dr d said in 29 years she's never
seen it
smith expects to go surgery on saturday
it's unclear along with action yikes
yeah he's got a hot second for sure and
also who who's out for a hot second
yep yeah but he went under this surgery
repair torn mcl i heard it's meniscus
mcl pcl which is a [ __ ] nightmare see
some damage to his ac right acl
definitely so it's mcl meniscus nacl
that's not fun
but he did
he had a successful surgery
yeah
hope he gets better he's a funny one to
watch
that sucks man definitely both those
guys out a hot second
and
this is uh i didn't know about this guy
but a lot a lot of fighters
yeah bjj guys are talking about this so
he was murdered in brazil
he was an eight-time world pgj champion
apparently took this cop down like that
mount and then they separated him the
cop just got his gunshot in the face you
heard he was a cop too like a off-duty
or something it doesn't make sense so
the guy just stole a bottle off of this
guy's table he took it back
his friends told him all right just
leave and then the guy came up and shot
him right in the head terrible yeah
awful awful
that's such a shame man
yeah man who shoots somebody in the
[ __ ] face i know
if it's a
horrible some kind of so weird but then
yeah yeah i don't
so yeah a lot of people are posting
about him yeah that's such a shame man
all right so
mozvidal started talking about
hamza shimayev
and then this is what he says
uh mazwa says i don't really think hamza
is good as they say he is i'm more of
see than believe guy i haven't seen
anything that makes a believer in this
guy yet i personally would love to break
his face once he starts selling
pay-per-views and [ __ ] like that i
wouldn't mind breaking his effing face
and then hamza posted this wake up buddy
yeah yeah knocked out by uzman yeah i
mean i get it for what mazda's done in
the game you know
that's fair he's a veteran going to i am
you know he's beat one guy's really beat
of note is gilbert burns and you know
there's a war
yeah i get it this would be a great
fight too hell yeah
uh some quick belcher ones so
patrice patricio pitbull ferrari is
going to fight adam boricks and spike
carlisle he's to find the ufc is going
to fight aj mckee it's a good fight
yeah
that's in long reach too so that's it
yeah aj mckees backyard home game for aj
oh yeah
this is also interesting tracy cortez
versus amanda rebus it's a fun fight
a little flyweight get down
and
we are fans of cortez here
yep so is brian
t city
so kane velazquez is pleading not guilty
to the attempted murder charge which is
interesting because if he somehow did a
deal with him you'd probably get less
time of something a plea deal but he's
completely not guilty at all wow i
wonder what his defense is uh his lawyer
said he's gonna they're gonna get
eyewitnesses
like they have eyewitnesses set up so he
has a powerful lawyer so i'm sure they
know what the hell they're doing god
speed kane we're rooting for here man
yeah
uh jon jones started posting yeah
it's interesting john you know what me
and my brother tell us jones is similar
to uh kevin durant where they're at such
a high level yet they pay attention to
social media they put so much
energy into it
so
jones posted a video of him hitting
mitts you know at a heavier weight and
you know looked a little slower
and then uh john next must have read the
comments and goes the biggest complaint
i hear from fight fans these days are
dude is taking too long he's not going
to fight sounds like people are becoming
impatient it's a great problem to have
i disagree it's it's been too long you
know it's been way too long you know
and then you get some skeptical hippo
eyes like why's it been so long well
you're putting weight on but you had
skeptical hip bites with his history and
stuff like that i think it was correct
me if i'm wrong but i'm pretty sure in
one of dana's last interviews he stayed
john's ready to go just waiting to see
what happens between steve bay and
france right now i'm focused on
controlling what i can that's packing on
the pounds which i think is a bad idea
but he's also the best to ever do it so
shut your mouth
for all those who said i looked a little
slow in my last training video and that
where do you pay attention to that
um i appreciate the added motivation
i'll push harder can't wait for you all
to see your boy in actual fight shape
everything has its process
i've been hearing whispers about
november but honestly i have no clue
been hearing that francis could possibly
be back on the table though not by
november and he goes back to this i
personally don't feel slow again he's
reading more comments i don't feel so
i'm aware that i'm not in camp i'm in a
bulking phase but like people judging
that version of me it could only work to
my advantage
[Music]
it looks like jon jones to me
[Music]
god he looks big
i don't know who's going to beat him
it's going to be so exciting he's just
starting to happen man it just needs to
freaking happen
what else can i do
let's see if there's any good ones oh
this was freaking dope so this is our
danielis container series i'll play it
for you again my god check it out how
much better contender series now that
better than ultimate fighter not even
close yeah
and all the talent that comes out of
there now
wow dan i can't believe you gave us this
man i saw this literally like oh that
was not so yeah let me see it again yeah
because i thought the other guy was
gonna win
that chest hat's sick
all right dude he is on
sixth street boom straight flush right
dog
yeah that was fantastic that was crazy i
love those fights those boys are fight
in
oh what do you think of hill's outfit
here
i don't know what to think i'm not mad
at it
okay
you know look good feel good fight good
yeah um
and jeff neil's hair was pretty crazy
that day too but uh this is a weird one
this is apparently a 600 versus 600
person boxing match in russia of course
that is
oh they do
it's very uh
it's very braveheart style
oh
it's so messy how do you decide who wins
oh and then even on the ground it goes
down
people should get in the back of the
head and [ __ ] this is a
[ __ ] show
yellow shirts versus the black shirts i
don't
know
i don't know let's say a real [ __ ] show
yeah
um
all right i think that's oh wait this
last one here
with his dad
oh man someone said already better than
joe martinez
[ __ ] the kid's so cute yeah is that
it that's it all right kids you got a
fight night this freaking saturday in
san diego home game for dominic cruz you
got cruz vs cheeto tough fight for your
boy cruise no matter where it's at
whoever wins it's a phenomenal story and
also the ufc has options than
bantamweight division whoever wins this
fight is in the talks to get a next
style shot or get the winner peter yan
sugar shawn so it's great for everybody
involved
i'm excited for it then cynthia calvia
not mad at it at all i'll be able to
watch this one too so i'm excited baby
gerald merchart
saturday night on espana spain plus get
you some and also next out of your big
pay-per-view you also got bkfc you got
perry versus michael venom page that's
bkfc 27 in london i think it's the 11am
start time
we might have to do a fight campaign for
that one that could be fun we haven't
done one for a bare knuckle that could
be interesting yeah who else you on the
card
let's see
paige
paige vanzant's the co-main event
boy that i mean everyone just looks
rough
bare knuckle man i mean just
take a look at that may character
telling these guys too good john
smells like travis brown sorta yeah i
mean they both have a beard
they're good john jesus christ
so you got paid yep michael venom page
and paige van zandt looks like it's page
on page page squared going down bare
knuckle that could be fun to a freaking
bare-knuckle
fight cowbest fight campaign for get the
boys out that could be fun 11am all
right maybe we'll see until we rally the
troops
that's not till uh the 20th though
that could be interesting yeah that's in
the uk 11 a.m
i dig it
is that it brother that's it all right
kids uh on the road for me i get most of
august off go on vacation with the fam
and i'll be doing sets around la ton of
spots this week in la i'm at the improv
back at the comedy store on wednesday
night i know chin wants to go yes i do
main room comedy store wednesday night
tuesday night the improv friday night
i'm at the laugh factory so i'm hitting
all three baby
so we have a bunch of sets around l.a
during uh middle of august end of august
the only date i have is in chicago it's
the den theater one night only 7 30 show
downtown chicago den theater brought to
you by rain body fuel baby that is the
den theater the trash panda summer tour
ends there so that's august 26 friday
in chicago den theater one night one
show only on the 27th at 11am is the
tough mudder right outside chicago
they're called the chicago tough mudder
but
it's about an hour outside chicago so uh
it's me versus the buttery bros if you
want to run with me alongside me and the
thick boy crew mark will be there mark
harley will be there haters will say
he's not going to be there but he is
going to be there
um
so that is august 27th that next morning
saturday it's 11 a.m heat use promo code
team brendan when you go to
toughmutter.com for that chicago heat
when you use promo code team branding
save 10 percent we have a shop and
friends august 31st and then appleton
wisconsin never been there appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
that thing's almost sold out that's a
thursday friday saturday in appleton
wisconsin and then ontario in probably
my favorite clubs ontario improv
california september 15th through the
17th and then boston literally top three
favorite cities my son's saying boston
for this reason that's how much i love
boston boston is september 28 through
october 1st get your tickets at
thickboy.com or
fatkz.com that's it kids be safe stay
thick
till next time like subscribe do all
that fun stuff love you guys i'm out